I'm gonna wake up tomorrow and be like
did that happen oh yes it did
Florence pew and Zach Braff were spotted
kissing champagne in hand I got them
overexcited the PDA moment comes after
Florence received her huge Oscar
nomination for Best Supporting Actress
for her role in Little Women I believe
we have some power over who we love it
isn't something that just happens to a
person I don't know if you're already
sick of hearing it but Oscar nominee how
do you feel I'll never be sick of
hearing it that's the coolest thing
about being nominated is that no for the
rest of my life it's safe to say girl is
living her best life the actress and the
former scrub star have been dating since
April even though the couple hasn't made
their red carpet debut Florence
addressed their 20-year age difference
on Instagram the 24 year old posted this
photo and Zach commented with a princess
emoji which led to a follower writing
here 44 years old in response
Florence clapped back writing and yet he
got it et spoke to the little women
actress on the day she received her
Oscar nom here's what the actress had to
say about celebrating with loved ones
it's so overwhelming it hasn't really
sunk in I just keep them talking about
it and I will at some point this
afternoon just sit and make sure that
it's fully resonated it's crazy it's
it's amazing will that be a moment when
you sit alone or is there anyone special
who you just want to soak the moment
anyway I think I'm gonna go see my
friends later and have a cheese and meat
board and have a bottle of wine and just
discuss how nuts this is
[Music]